hey guys dr. Burke here I want to show
you how to correct posture so I'm sure
your parents used to tell you to sit up
tall right unfortunately that was bad
advice because here's what happens you
have two sets of muscles you have all
the muscles on the front part of your
body and all the muscles on the back
part of your body so when you're
slouched like this the muscles on the
front part of the body are too tight so
if you were to stretch them they tend to
be like a rubber band and just rebound
and come back you know and it's not bad
to stretch that way but from yours of
sitting back and you know watching TV
like this and slouching a much better
approach would be to stretch the muscles
in the back and I'm going to show you
how to do that too that'll allow you to
come up without really any effort okay
so this is what you do for poor posture
to your kids even tell them just have
them slouch more so you really want to
stretch the back muscle so I'm going to
hunch my back as much as I can so I'm
just going to arch my back like this I'm
going to press down and when I come all
the way down this way okay so I'm going
to do that about ten times alright I'm
going to hunch my back and make my
posture as bad as possible
forcing my head to come down - okay so
I'm just going to do this
okay so you want to just hunt you back
now what's going to happen if you after
about 10 times your it's going to be
like you're just going to come right up
naturally it's really easy to sit up
tall now okay it's just when you do this
don't mention my name if you're doing it
in public right but I'm just kidding the
point is that you always want to work on
the opposite muscles okay
so this whole thing we have to
constantly stretch back doesn't always
work so you could even do both ways but
this is something that's been neglected
but I want you to try this right now as
you're sitting in your chair do it 10
times and see if it doesn't allow your
posture to come up without any effort at
all and even your head over your body
and put your comments below so go ahead
and subscribe to my channel and I will
see you in the next video